conférence sur les armements chimiques à
paris l'urss de sites sans attendre de
commencer à détruire ses stocks mais les
petits pays n'entendent pas renoncer à
ce qu'il considère être comme la force
de dissuasion pauvres au pôle sud
greenpeace contre l'exploitation
industrielle de la banquise vous
empêcher de la construction d'un terrain
d'aviation par la france
nîmes trois mois plus tard 90 jours
après la catastrophe nous sommes allés
enquêter sur place bilan contrasté et de
toute façon
300 habitations construites dans les
zones dangereuses sont condamnés à la
destruction
madame monsieur bonsoir
loin très loin de nous et pourtant
peut-être très proche par ses
conséquences sur les équilibres naturels
de la planète
plusieurs grandes nations dont la france
ont décidé d'exploiter les énormes
richesses minières potentiel du pôle sud
dans le monde plusieurs personnalités
dont le commandant cousteau s'élèvent
contre cette exploitation industrielle
et à cette occasion l'organisation
pacifiste et écologiste greenpeace
refait parler d'elle en s'opposant sur
le terrain à la construction d'une piste
d'atterrissage par la france hier soir
des incidents ont même opposé des
militants de greenpeace et des ouvriers
chargés des travaux
quels sont les enjeux économiques et
écologiques de cette affaire jacques
vieux
sans bien sûr chassait le pingouin les
français de la base dumont d'urville ont
sérieusement perturbé la tranquillité de
ce paradis du bout du monde en
construisant une piste d'atterrissage de
plus d'un kilomètre à l'endroit même où
les manchots adélie font leur nid
l'incident entre les ouvriers français
les militants de greenpeace a eu lieu au
cours d'une visite de la base française
comme ici l'année dernière par une
délégation de l'organisation écologiste
présente en antarctique depuis deux ans
et qui entend s'opposer à toute
exploitation industrielle du dernier
continue encore presque vierge avec
approché notre maison et c'est encore
une fois autre chose une autre jour est
ce qu'il ya eu des blessés parmi les
ouvriers français et parmi les militants
de greenpeace
jean françois houssin le commandant de
la base française a dû arrêter les
travaux
cet après midi à paris monsieur le
pensec ministre de l'un des deux hommes
tom affirmé que le dialogue devait
continuer avec greenpeace et que la
france avait mis en oeuvre des moyens
importants pour préserver
l'environnement
ce qui n'est pas suffisant pour les
militants écologistes sur ce continent
du bout du monde sont présents une
quinzaine de pays avec une cinquantaine
de base scientifique en construisant une
piste d'aviation
la france veut conforter sa présence au
pôle sud et faciliter les liaisons avec
les équipes scientifiques
l'avenir dira si la conférence de paris
sur les armements chimiques aura des
conséquences concrètes en tout cas elle
ne s'est pas résumée depuis son
ouverture hier samedi à des discours
feutré de diplomates le ministre des
affaires étrangères soviétique monsieur
edouard chevardnadzé a même fait une
déclaration précise indiquant que son
pays allait sans attendre un éventuel
accord international commencé à détruire
son stock d'armement chimie le
secrétaire d'état américain monsieur
georges souche a bien entendu accueilli
avec satisfaction cette décision georges
bortoli philipp etter
le ministre soviétique chez barnes et a
dit ce matin que son pays commencerait
dès cette année à détruire ses stocks
d'armes chimiques
l'américain choles lui a dit ce matin sa
satisfaction cette prise de position qui
scelle un nouveau rapprochement des deux
grands satisfaction même si monsieur
schultz le sait bien
cette destruction pour être complète
durera très longtemps quel que soit le
chiffre réel des stocks soviétique était
actuellement comme stocks d'armes
chimiques détenu par l'urss gpu mobiles
nous l'avons déjà annoncé nous avons
annoncé 50 mille tonnes
ce n'est pas une petite quantité c'est
même beaucoup attendent
concrètement combien d'années faut-il
pour détruit un stock pareil c'est un
problème nous allons terminer cette
usine dans un proche avenir pour
détruire nos armes
la pratique montrera alors combien de
temps il faut pour les détruire des
problèmes écologiques vont apparaître
et pas seulement écologique la
destruction des fusées à moyenne portée
révèle déjà des problèmes compliqués
plus compliqué même que ceux de leurs
constructions je faisais cela je le sais
ça se gagne à craquer c'est à dire que
pendant un certain nombre d'années rss
va rester la plus grande puissance en
matière d'armes chimiques avant goût
fish et les détruire il y aura
probablement une période à ce genre chat
genève en énergie aussi cet aspect du
problème sérieusement celui qui a le
plus d'armes chimiques devra adopter le
rythme le plus rapide pour les détruire
les etats unis doivent faire cela et
l'urss aussi simone attaque
j'ai cru comprendre dans votre discours
de ce matin que vous regrettiez que
votre pays est construit tellement
d'armes chimiques
ce message a l'air nous le regrettons
tous et les états unis est ce qui ne le
regarde pas sans aucun doute tous les
gens honnêtes le regrette
pourquoi avons-nous constitué de telles
réserves il ne fallait pas le faire il
fallait arrêter la production
il fallait conclure un accord pour
interdire la production mais maintenant
nous avons probablement tous mûri et la
conférence de paris montre qu'il ya des
perspectives de solutions réponse rien
n'est sûr alors vous avez dit que
c'était une vaste inc qui restaient à
prendre la bastille c'est parce qu'ils
en ont la bastille deux conférences en
une pourrait-on dire à propos de cette
réunion de paris la première de nant
vous l'avez entendu la parole aux
grandes puissances d'accord pour essayer
de détruire les armements chimiques en
leur possession
la seconde conférence entre les petits
pays des points les plus chauds du globe
et qui n'entendent pas se séparer de
cette arme de dissuasion
alors que les grands gardent leur
armement nucléaire est à mille lieues
des discours feutré des diplomates
depuis 48 heures l'iran et l'irak
s'accusent mutuellement d'utiliser ces
armements chimiques accusations photo
terrible tous les arguments ont été
employés dominique verdeilhan des photos
difficilement supportable témoignage
d'une vie stoppée net
des extraits de déclarations de
ministres et militaires irakiens
justifiant le droit de leur pays à se
défendre par tous les moyens un tract
distribué aujourd'hui par des iraniens
pour appuyer leurs accusations sur les
attaques chimiques irakiennes durant
huit ans de conflit
cette distribution de documents iranien
cet après midi au palais de l'unesco est
un nouvel épisode du bras de fer qui a
opposé dès hier le chef de la délégation
irakienne au ministre iranien des
affaires étrangères
à la pjj a au nord de l'irak
26 mars 88 les bombardements de gaz par
les forces irakiennes contre les kurdes
aurait fait près de 5000 morts hier le
ministre iranien avait demandé que la
conférence de paris condamne l'irak pour
les blessures qu'il a infligé à 50 mille
victimes iranienne dont 10% était morte
par ses seules attaques chimie cet
après-midi le ministre irakien n'a pas
directement répondu aux critiques de
l'iran soulignant seulement que l'irak
respecter le protocole de genève
interdisant l'utilisation d'armes
chimiques parmi les ministres présents à
cette conférence de paris celui des
affaires étrangères d'israël monsieur
moche et à rennes ce qui est notre
invité ce soir en direct de l'ambassade
d'israël
monsieur le ministre bonsoir il sera
elle se protège contre les armements
chimiques on l'a souvent vu à la
télévision
mais israël possède l'état d'israël
possède-t-il désarmement chimiques comme
vous le savez notre pays a vu
l'utilisation par d'autres pays d'armes
chimiques
le tchad par exemple d'irak et on venait
de voir les photos à l'écran ces pays
donc du moyen-orient utilisent ces armes
chimiques aussi bien contre les
populations civiles ou ce que contre les
militaires
l'irak la libye affirme être en état de
guerre contre israël donc nous nous
sommes nous nous sentons directement
menacés par ces armes chimiques et para
la dévolution de l'armement gimmick plus
d'ailleurs que les autres pays
représentés à la conférence de l'unesco
donc de ce fait il faut nous préparer
pour nous défendre contre ces armes
chimiques mais quant à nous nous avons
l'intention l'afflux ferme d'amener
l'abolition complète d'armes chimiques
mais est-ce que vous en possédez vous
n'avez pas répondu à ma question est ce
que vous possédez des armes chimiques
en fait nous avons fait des préparatifs
pour nous défendre au cas où nous
serions attaqués par l'amt chimiques
bien donc vous possédez d'une certaine
façon des armes chimiques les plusieurs
états arabes explique leurs besoins en
armement chimiques en disant qu'israël
possède l'armé nucléaire
donc il faut se protéger quand israël et
que l'armement chimique est un moyen se
protéger ça ne me paraît pas très
logique parce que lorsqu'on regarde ce
qui se passe en irak c'est après après
tout qui se servent le plus de larmes
chimiques et bien ils ne se sont pas
servis de cette arme contre israël
et parce qu'ils n'ont rien à craindre de
l'état d'israël n'y a pas de frontière
commune entre irak entre l'irak israël
alors les états unis en ce moment
monsieur moshe arens parallèlement à la
conférence de paris accuse les libyens
de produire des armes chimiques est ce
que le gouvernement israélien votre
gouvernement par l'intermédiaire de ces
informations ou de ses services secrets
conforte la position américaine est ce
que vous pensez vraiment que le colonel
kaddafi fabrique des armements chimiques
enfin nous ne pensons pas qu'un grand
complexe industriel tel que celui
d'acteur en libye servent uniquement à
faire des produits pharmaceutiques nous
avons ré toutes les raisons de penser
qu'il s'agit d'un complexe industriel
destiné à la fabrication d'armes
chimiques
dernière question et une seule question
parce que nous n'avons pas le temps ce
soir à propos des palestiniens vous avez
rencontré à paris ce matin monsieur
george shultz le secrétaire d'état
américain pour lui dire que les
pourparlers avec
monsieur yasser arafat n'était une
mauvaise chose pour la paix alors
puisque vous ne croyez pas le
gouvernement israélien ne croit pas à la
sincérité du leader palestinien
est ce que vous ne pensez pas que il
serait peut-être plus simple pour israël
d'avoir l'audace comme l'a vécu monsieur
béguines à une certaine époque avec
monsieur sadate de discuter avec celui
qui finalement est tout de même en face
de vous chaque jour et depuis depuis
près de quarante ans maintenant
lp est représentée par monsieur arafat
le lp donc est une organisation
terroriste la plus grande organisation
terroriste internationale responsable
d'être c'était abominable que le monde
le monde connaît depuis la deuxième
guerre mondiale
et lorsque les états unis reconnaît
cette organisation leur lui donne une
certaine légitimité il ya ceux ci ne
peut qu'encourager l'escaladé de la
violence et du terrorisme et nous ne
ferons rien coup et cela n'encouragera
pas la paix en tout cas monsieur le
ministre je vous remercie
à propos de la libye justement bons
mouvements de parler à l'instant après
la surprenante invitation du colonel
kadhafi aux journalistes étrangers de
venir vérifier sur place que les
accusations américaines affirmant qu'une
usine d'armement chimiques fonctionner
sur le territoire libyen était fausse
et bien tout aussi surprenante volte
face à ces mêmes journalistes ont été
priés ce matin de déguerpir purement et
simplement après avoir eu tout juste le
droit à une excursion en autocar et un
coup d'oeil vraiment très rapide sur
l'enceinte de la fameuse usine de
produits pharmaceutiques entre
guillemets selon les libyens dans
l'autocar nos envoyés spéciaux gilles
rabin france brisset c'est tout ce que
les 200 journalistes qui ont pu faire le
voyage à rapt à auront pu voir de la
fameuse usine chimique de khadda fit
quelques images volées à la vigilance
des policiers accompagnateurs après la
tombée de la nuit et à 800 mètres de
distance
en revanche tout au long de ce reportage
très organisé les journalistes auront eu
le loisir d'observer de nombreuses
manifestations populaires de soutien au
colonel kadhafi tout aussi spontanée les
unes que les autres
les jeunes d'abord puis les femmes
message sous-entendu à destination des
états unis
si vous bombardez lusine vous ferez des
victimes parmi ces innocents qui habite
nombreux près de lusine quand le hasard
permet de filmer ces hommes qu'on cache
sous des passe-montagnes des
travailleurs immigrés thaïlandais sud
coréens et philippins que de véritables
marchands d'esclaves modernes vendent à
bas prix dans le monde arabe
un policier anonyme intervient aussitôt
conférence de presse avec double
traduction simultanée en anglais et en
français
buffet et langue de bois qui est devenue
la le minaret de la paix et de la 2de de
la dir et de bandes direction juste
après cette visite les journalistes ont
appris qu'ils étaient tous expulsés de
libye de l' usine chimique de rapt à ils
n'auront rien vu aux questions que pose
la cohérence de l'attitude libyenne ils
n'obtiendront pas de réponses
incompréhensibles inextricable liban
dans le sud du pays dans la banlieue et
dans la partie ouest de la capitale
beyrouth des milices musulmanes chi hier
encore alliés s'affrontent très durement
des dizaines de morts un paradoxe sont
leurs victimes d'hier les palestiniens
qui s'interpose aujourd'hui entre les
deux factions jacques merlino les
premiers affrontements ont eu lieu dans
le sud du liban près de la ville de
saïda tôt ce matin des miliciens du
hezbollah pro iranien ont attaqué six
villages tenus par les hommes d'amal
prosyriens des affrontements très
violents puisque le premier bilan fait
état de 28 morts et d'une cinquantaine
de blessés
les combats ont duré cinq heures et se
sont terminées au profit du mouvement
pro syrien qui a repris le contrôle
faratas mais peu après la tension
gagnait beyrouth ouest et les miliciens
des deux bords s'affrontaient à l'armé
automatique et à la roquette anti char
dans la soirée sur ordre de yasser
arafat
les combattants du fatah se sont
interposés entre les différents
combattants un rôle nouveau pour cette
organisation
en france georges besse pdg de la régie
renault assassiné devant son appartement
devant chez lui à paris le 17 novembre
1986 demain s'ouvre à paris toujours le
procès de ces deux meurtrières nathalie
ménigon joëlle aubron
dans le box il y aura également leur
complice jean marc rouillan et georges
cipriani bref à eux quatre ils formaient
le noyau dur du groupe action terroriste
action directe
hervé brusini dominique tian
qui a tué georges besse près de deux ans
dans quête pour répondre à cette
question
les quatre accusés d'action directe ont
refusé d'assister à l'acte majeur du
dossier
cette reconstitution pendant six heures
le juge d'instruction vie demain va
diriger ce travail minutieux 7 sommes
consternés de ne pouvoir en dire plus
c'est francis verhaeghe
le chauffeur du patron de la régie
renault oui c'est bien ce à peu près
nous nous sommes garés là dit il et
comme d'habitude c'est vers 20 heures
que je les déposer devant chez lui
il est sorti à récupérer son imperméable
et sa serviette et puis il a traversé le
boulevard
moi je n'ai rien vu je suis reparti
presque aussitôt horaires et itinéraires
toujours régulier georges besse ne
prenait aucune précaution pour sa
sécurité il ne se sentait pas menacé
pourtant des témoins avaient observé le
jour du crime le comportement suspect de
quatre personnes si témoignages sont
formels ce sont bien deux femmes qui ont
tiré sur georges besse
dès leur arrivée sur les lieux les
enquêteurs rassemblent tous les éléments
matériels de l'assassinât trois douilles
de 9 mm ainsi qu'une balle du même
calibre
très vite les policiers soupçonnent
action directe d'avoir commis l'attentât
première confirmation dès le lendemain
un passant découvre au métro raspail
ce tract dactylographié analyses en
laboratoire les spécialistes affirment
que la frappe est bien identique à celle
du texte de revendication de l'attentât
contre guy branagh l'un des responsables
du patronat français
trois mois plus tard plus aucun doute le
groupe dissous explique son geste et le
choix de sa cible dans 14 pages envoyé à
l' agence france-presse
le tournant décisif va se produire ici à
la ferme de vitry aux loges
la planque des quatre membres d'action
directe les policiers découvrent tout un
stock d'éléments matériels en relation
avec l'assassinât de georges besse sur
une étagère de la bibliothèque une
vingtaine de lambeaux de cuir les restes
de la serviette que portait ce soir de
l'attentât
le patron de la régie renault une
enveloppe kraft au nom de l'entreprise
de georges besse et dans la pièce de
séjour un lot d'une cinquantaine de
cassettes vidéo
deux d'entre elles sont intitulés hi-fi
et alexandre le bienheureux en fait de
divertissement il s'agit de repérage
devant le domicile de georges besse et
cela près de six mois avant l'attentât
enfin et surtout des armes parmi elles
un revolver smith & wesson selon les
experts c'est ce revolver qui attirait
la balle extraite du crâne de georges
besse
pendant cinq jours les quatre inculpés
du dossier seront face à la cour
spéciale joëlle aubron nathalie ménigon
sont accusées d'assassinats
jean marc rouillan georges cipriani de
complicité d'assassinât
mais ils risquent tous les quatre la
même peine la réclusion à perpétuité
la politique maintenant monsieur raymond
barre au club de la presse d'europe du
mur un première personnalité hors de la
majorité a estimé que la loi pasqua sur
l'immigration devait être amendé
montbard je crois que certaines
dispositions de la loi pasqua devait
être amendé je vous rappelle que lorsque
la loi a été votée avec un certain
nombre de mes collègues à l'assemblée
nationale
nous avons essayé de faire passer à sa
demande d'amendement certains ont été
retenus d'autres n'ont pas été je crois
que il y a un travail de deux de
complément ou d'aménagement à faire ceux
qui ont été indiquées dans les
circulaires de monsieur jean me
paraissent mériter une approbation sur
le même thème monsieur philippe seguin
au grand jury rtl le monde est la
première personnalité du rpr cette fois
ci à ne pas se montrer hostile au
souhait du président de la république de
voir ce assouplir la réglementation sur
l'immigration en france par ailleurs
monsieur seguin craint qu'une alliance
centriste socialiste ne rejette très à
droite son mouvement le rpr il le dit
philippe seguin la reconstitution d'une
troisième force c'est-à-dire d'une
alliance pour l'essentiel des
socialistes et des centristes
je ne suis pas certain que cette
alliance on donnerait davantage demain
mais je lui vois surtout d'autres
inconvénients
c'est d'une part le risque de faire
remonter le parti communiste au
détriment du parti socialiste et l'autre
risque c'est de pousser le rpr et les
membres de l'udf qui n'accepteraient pas
cette solution dans une dérive droitière
qui serait très préjudiciable non
seulement à ces partis politiques eux
mêmes mais également à notre pays
en cas de leur retour au pouvoir
un fait divers un vrai qui a pour cadre
le village de prades dans les pyrénées
occidentales
les villageois cache depuis quelques
mois maintenant un jeune guinéen venu en
france pour être entre autres la vedette
de l'équipe locale de football
malheureusement en juin dernier sa
demande d'asile politique a été refusée
depuis le jeune homme
dans la clandestinité valérie fournis ou
jérôme bréhat et bernard koné matemale
un petit village des pyrénées-orientales
fait de la résistance
depuis trois mois les 200 habitants
cache un clandestin guinéens en dépit de
la loi une loi qu'ils considèrent
inhumaine alors le maire en tête il le
protège c'est un gars qui habitait ici
depuis quatre ans qui a sympathisé
hommes qui peuvent tout le monde n'avait
les jeunes en priorité bien sûr qui fait
partie de l'équipe de foot qui bossent
et qui ne finit à la charge de personnes
les gars n'ont pas compris qu'ils
puissent être jetés dehors pour nous -
chasser le lièvre chasse le sanglier ou
chasse à l'isard quand il est ouvert on
ne chasse pas l'homme
papy comme il l'appelle et leurs amis à
tous pour sa gentillesse et puis il est
leur meilleur joueur de foot
jamais il ne le laisseront être expulsé
danse mobilise tout cela et puis on
espère qu'il restera définie ce serait
injuste pourquoi parce que ce qui fait
partie du village parce qu'il vit avec
nous depuis un certain temps parce qu'on
a appris à le connaître
et qu'ont acceptées parmi les citations
qui est réduit à dix je pense pas que je
souhaite pas que d'autres gens soient
dans une station à laquelle je suis en
ce moment je suis content pour personne
vous avez l'intention de devenir
français d'abord là c'était procède de
faire tout ce que fait un procès devenir
français pour papy ce sera officialisé
son intégration réussie dans ce village
son village
mais combien de temps hébergée de maison
en maison
papy devra attendre la régularisation de
sa situation
le dossier du journal il est important
souvent de s'intéresser à nouveau à ceux
qui ne font plus la une de l'actualité
ainsi à nîmes
trois mois plus tard nous sommes allés
nous rendre compte de ce qui avait été
fait pour reloger aider les victimes de
cette terrible inondation
beaucoup de choses ont été faites
d'autres vont moins rapidement et de
toute façon rien ne sera plus vraiment
comme avant car la décision a été d'ores
et déjà prises de détruire plusieurs
centaines de maisons construites sur des
zones dangereuses en quête de gens
payent eux et patrick voix 3 octobre
les millions de tonnes d'eau s'abattent
sur nîmes voici la même rue trois mois
plus tard vitrine et voiries sont
remises en état
partout dans le centre la ville n'a
stoppé aucun grand programme comme la
couverture hivernale des arènes ici
cette camionnette va livrer des meubles
à des sinistrés plus de 2000 familles
ont ainsi été ré équiper par nîmes
solidarité le fonds des municipales les
secours financier ont aussi été
accordées aux plus démunis dans ce
quartier richelieu le plus touché après
les assurances qui ont versé les plus
fortes indemnités
plusieurs aides sont venus de l'état et
des dons privés
gérard seguin est un de ceux qui ont
tout perdu le 3 octobre et sarre près
4000 francs ne pouvait pas grand chose
pour l'aider
gérard seguin ont assuré comme deux
habitants sur trois étaient indemnisées
par l'état pour le logement la mairie
pour le mobilier passé beaucoup
d'améliorations et vous voyez à part les
murs évidemment elle n'a pas bougé mais
au point de vue mais j'ai quand même
remonter un peu ça me redonne goût à la
vie valeur moyenne des meubles 7000
francs
voilà les faits notables bar télé quand
même c'est quand même agréable
bon alors il faut dire qu'il ya quand
même un petit point noir dans l'histoire
c'est ce qui vous est arrivé cette nuit
quelqu'un a forcé la première fois de ma
salle à manger et venus fouiller
l'appartement et même que le chef d'un
tireur avait des enveloppes avec une
petite somme d'argent et ils me l'ont
emporté puis il faut dire que cette
catastrophe
ça paraît ges amené beaucoup de
marginaux de désoeuvrés et le tout qu'y
sol à l'affût et à la moindre faute
profite de l'inattention et de tout un
quartier déstabiliser avec des logements
abandonnés dans la tente des travaux
c'est un des visages de richelieu
l'autre c'est celui de l'effort de la
remise en état et propriétaires qui
s'engagent à relouer après travaux sont
fortement aidé une antenne a été ouverte
pour les habitants les i reçoit pour les
aider à monter leur dossier et
locataires relogés ailleurs paie un
loyer plus élevé mais à fond dès prend
en charge la différence
quant aux propriétaires des solutions
exceptionnelles sont mobilisés pour eux
trente mille francs en moyenne par
logement fin mars ont été ouverts ainsi
300 chantiers pour la première fois
depuis trois mois muriel et pascal
brunet reviennent voir le logement
qu'ils habitaient le 3 octobre il
l'avait quittée peu de jours après et
antenne 2 les avaient eux aussi
rencontré à cette époque relogés dans
une hlm de quatre pièces il en avait
deux les brunes et veulent tourner la
page
maintenant on est allé là-bas et puis il
ya rien qui a été fait on voit qu'on a
pas entendu après lui parce qu'autrement
on s'ancre dans le bassin toby d'abord
je veux pas retourner au coeur de
chaussons s'est pas spécialement avait
chez eux mêmes
même au rez-de-chaussée je ne vois pas
et richelieu qu'est ce que ça voudrait
dire dans ma vie
je préfère ne pas parler bon 2 s'est
inclinée en défense et c'est là où c'est
que j'ai tout table une maison coupée en
deux par l'eau du cadre dans lequel
elles étaient construites les cadres au
ce sont ces fossés qui deviennent
ruisseau avec les orages et une autre
maison dévastée
pour la même raison 12 cents maisons ont
été ainsi sinistrés hors du centre ville
rien n'a changé depuis le 3 octobre
même chose pour le cimetière protestant
au confluent des cadereau d'alès et du
camp planer et même chose pour les
routes quelques maisons parmi les plus
touchées ont été détruites dans le cadre
du plan orsec
dans la semaine qui a suivi le sinistre
en voici une les propriétaires des
autres maisons attendent pour
reconstruire ou pour détruire
il ya 300 maisons 300 qui sont
construites dans le livre qu'a d'euros
il ya l'école de l'eau bouillie qui l'a
sortie donne dans le cadre qu'est ce que
vous allez faire rêver les prix oui il
faut aller détruire
disons que s'il faut détruire dans
l'intérêt et la sécurité de ceux qui
sont également à prénom mais il ya
également en amont on voit bien ici les
constructions en plein milieu du
cadereau plusieurs voisins aujourd'hui
se désole l'un a perdu un hangar de 100
mètres de long
l'autre un garage n'avons pas que nous
mêmes il était construit par celui qui a
construit la salle de bal et de la fait
sans permission
mais là mais commune était du parti
alors comprenez ça bien joué pour lui
voulait dire que la politique a joué à
ouidah produits tic à jouer c'est pas
moi qui livrait des livres et les
produits locaux
c'est le préfet qui signait les permis
de construire et non point le maire mais
avec avis concerne certainement des des
permis de construire ont été données
sinon dans le lit des cadres ont au
moins à proximité des cadres oh vous
savez ce problème des déséquilibres des
eaux pluviales c'est un problème
universel
et qui en france est traitée
malheureusement dans beaucoup de villes
de façon un petit peu anarchique et pas
du tout raisonnable pour protéger nîmes
contre un nouveau déluge un plan
gouvernemental est en préparation
les nîmois en attendant m le leur en
pratique d'abord des bassins de retenue
14 sont prévues dans la garrigue deux
seulement ont été construits comme ici
le long d'un golf
ensuite on creuse les fossés ainsi à la
naissance du cadereau d'alès
mais les choses devraient être moins
facile en ville ou le cadereau passe
sous les rues en aval enfin il faudrait
des bassins avant que le cadre on se
jette dans le vistre mais plusieurs
communes devraient donner des terrains
une solidarité sans doute plus difficile
à obtenir que celle des particuliers qui
ont donné pour les sinistrés de nîmes
toujours intéressant de suivre les
affaires on apprend beaucoup de choses
pour terminer je vous donne les
résultats du tiercé et du kart et qui se
sont courues cet après midi à vincennes
pour gagner il fallait jouer le 15 le 4
et le 3 ça rapporte 54000 france est un
beau tiercé
et puis le kart est encore plus beau
puisque pour s'y feront en ajoutant le
set
vous avez le tout pour 236 1685 francs
tour voilà ce journal est terminée josé
blanc la pierre vous présente tout de
suite après les prévisions météo demain
philippe gassot pour les dernières
informations vous le retrouver aux
alentours de 23h et puis demain soir ici
même à 20h vous retrouverez hervé claude
je vous souhaite une excellente soirée
une excellente un excellent une
excellente semaine voilà je vais y
arriver c'est au féminin et puis moi je
vous donne rendez-vous à samedi prochain
bonsoir à la semaine proche